Togashi has revealed the ending of
Hunter Hunter and surprisingly this
video is not clickbait I know like I am
as surprised as you are but Yoshi her
toosi has preemptively released an
ending to the series just in case he
does not live to complete it not just
one ending actually four four whole
potential endings one of which is the
ending that we'll have if Togashi
doesn't get to complete the series and
this information comes to us courtesy of
a Japanese variety show tagashi himself
was not actually on the show which isn't
too surprising due to his health and
generally introverted he very rarely
makes public appearances however Togashi
provided the hosts with handwritten text
containing the four potential hunt
Hunter endings so I don't like being
pessimistic but if we're being realistic
here this may be the closest to an
ending that we'll ever get so this is
this a pretty big deal because Tashi is
currently 57 years old and yeah that's
still quite young but at the current
pace of the manga just yeah I I don't
know so these full potential endings are
all quite radically different and
there's a good reason for that one of
the reasons why Togashi fascinates and
captivates me so much is because he's
known for preparing alternate endings
for each AR quite famously Togashi goes
out of his way to right endings where
the villains win and the protagonist
flat out die which probably explains why
gone gets thoroughly brutalized in most
docks because what I've always suspected
is that Togashi writes his good ending
the one where the heroes win and live
happily ever after and then he writes
the bad ending the one where the
villains win and the heroes die but then
for the actual ending he Blends them
together which is why Honda Honda has
the sense of realism despite taking
place in a very magical world because
the end of almost every art can be
summed up as the heroes won but at what
cost and also were the villains really
that bad sometimes yes other times not
as yes which this text very much affirms
but let's get into tekashi's words
regarding the ending I have prepared
three scenarios a b and c when
considering the proportional reaction
from readers ranging from Satisfaction
to dissatisfaction ending a is deemed
satisfactory by 80% and unsatisfactory
by 20% this does not necessarily imply a
high rating but for me reaching it will
be secure in a way that doesn't
complicate matters with excessive
criticism in my belief so before any of
you comment below there is also an
ending D which tagashi will bring up in
a bit which I only say because I know
someone's going to be like oh you said
four endings and only three because for
whatever reason people love to pause and
comment before they've seen the whole
video basically though togashi's
approach to the end of Hunter Hunter is
actually very scientific in nature he's
prepared this spectrum of endings and
the reason why he's done that is almost
certain cly due to his experience with u
hakushu and this this isn't quite the
video to go into that but tagashi was so
disappointed in the ending of that
series that in the final volume he wrote
an apology letter to the fans because he
knew that it was unsatisfactory for both
them and himself but he had to stop
drawing the manga for a variety of
physical and mental health based reasons
so it's just what we got but back to
Hunter Hunter as for ending B opinions
will be divided similarly between
satisfaction and dissatisfaction for
ending C I anticipate a satisfaction
rate of 10% and dissatisfaction rate of
90% why do I keep it present even with a
high rate of dissatisfaction that's
because it's my personal preference but
fundamentally I want to think to the
utmost extent about an ending to the
point where I might not choose any of
these three and create what I find most
enjoyable which is my ideal goal so to
recap ending a is probably a very basic
Shonen ending everything wraps up more
or less satisfactory and 80% of people
go just well played Togashi well played
I am satisfied whereas ending B is 50 50
you're either going to love it or you're
going to hate it but ending c ending C
that is the most curious one because
it's the ending that Togashi predicts as
the one that would dissatisfy the vast
majority of readers but it's also the
one that he wants to do the most and I
can't help but feel insanely curious
about it because even if it is deemed
awful that's probably the option that I
would want him to go with Hunter Hunter
to this point has always been a story
completely at the mercy of togashi's
interests arcs are cut short some
stories are started and never wrapped up
the entire genre of Hunter Hunter goes
goes through several different complete
shifts and we've even replaced our main
character at this point so I think he's
overreacting a bit about ending se but
then again I'd also love to know how
many if any times that he's gone with
that option for ending an arc because I
would suspect that it's usually more
along the lines of ending B Because
Hunter Hunter rocks do tend to end in
that sort of 50/50 split but as promised
here is ending D to give you a clearer
picture I will share scenario D which
fell out of the candidate scenarios for
the ending if fate takes me before
finishing the manga consider it the
manga's ending I would be happy if you
forgive me for that so that's a very
depressing thought but with that in mind
here's the full ending which I'm going
to read in its entirety before we start
diving into it and discussing it the
ending D next to the lake a girl named
jyn holding a fishing rod stands
motionless suddenly the rod shakes
violently and Jinn startled exclaims I
got him I got the lak Lord she
skillfully lifts the lak Lord onto her
shoulders and stands before a woman
saying as promised I caught the lake
Lord mom JY approaches the woman and
passionately declares you must not tell
me again you must become a hunter the
woman with no tricks left nods her head
jyn still carrying the lake CL on her
shoulder walks away the mother comments
to her husband that jyn's dream is to
never leave the island and inherit their
place the father agrees laughing and the
mother expresses her dissatisfaction
saying perhaps her desires will change
later but I want to know you and JY why
are you like this surely it's because of
the blood of Grandma Mito and Grandma
NOCO the woman seems unaware that
Grandma Mito and Grandma NOCO are not
related by blood and the father Smiles
knowingly the woman expressing her
unwillingness as mother adds but Grandpa
gone was a famous Hunter and this girl
will one day leave the island jyn
insists I will never leave although she
is no longer visible in the heart of the
forest she hears her parents
conversation and responds defiantly the
father amused says you have a sharp eye
the scene changes to the shop continuing
its work from Meo days the lake Lord has
been cleanly cut and its internal part
sorted JY thinks to herself while
working mom never understands when
Grandpa speaks joyfully about his
memories of being a hunter Grandma NOCO
quietly moves away from her seat every
time Grandpa gon affirms her belief is
heard from someone she strikes The
Cutting Board forcefully with a knife
I'm tired of this to wait for someone's
return after months and years of sadness
crushes my heart I make someone wait for
me then the door opens and a warm voice
Echoes a chubby little child enters
holding a plant the child exclaims I
caught the lord of the lake for real
well let's honor the whole island with
it Jin replies I always always wanted to
be with the person I want to be with
together always the child agrees both of
them with broad Smiles on their faces
cook the food a bird flies away from the
island over a town and its people the
son of one of them the daughter of
another and the grandchild of another
live in different places exchanging
Smiles they might be the children of
that character and the grandchildren of
that character the bird flies away into
the distance in the background a figure
watches the scene the end all right
let's dissect this because there's a lot
in here that you may have missed firstly
I should say that this was translated by
Pew piece on Twitter and his English as
you may have noticed isn't the greatest
nor his pragmatic translations in my
experience so I would really really love
for someone else to take a step at this
but you get the general idea ending D is
essentially a classic bookend we began
Hunter Hunter with gone catching the
lord of the lake or the master of the
swamp however you prefer to refer to it
and doing so was gon's invitation to
Adventure he'd passed that test allowing
him to leave the island and start the
series whereas this one is a reversal we
have jyn doing the exact same thing but
refusing The Call to Adventure which is
giving the series permission to end it's
closing the loop although it does also
leave the door open for Jin leaving
later because her mother says that one
day she'll leave so as a reader you get
to take that as you prefer this either
breaks or perpetuates the freak cycle
now JY is obviously a descendant of gone
specifically his granddaughter and a
character named NOCO is mentioned who
you may or more likely may not remember
as the little girl who appeared in
chapter 1 and episode one of both anime
series in the Manga she doesn't
particularly stand out however the 2011
anime makes sure to zero win on her
reaction to gone leaving with some of
the uh the good old crying but from
there NOCO is never seen again in any
medium however gone does mention her in
the manga in chapter 64 the implication
has always been that NOCO had a bit of a
crush on gone and it's not at all
surprising that they would end up
together especially since gone did state
that NOCO was quite literally the only
other child on the island so options
were always going to be pretty limited
but jyn's parents are a big part of this
ending and if I had to guess I would say
that jyn's father is gone son because
the mother seems very unaware of the
family Dynamic and goes so far as to
assume that Mito and NOCO are related by
blood whereas the father has this sort
of knowing knowledge and also the mother
doesn't understand why jyn wouldn't
leave the island to become a hunter
taking advantage of that more gonging
Adventure lust and actually comments
that jyn may have inherited more of the
muto and NOCO bloodline of while staying
at home so I would definitely say that
the mother probably joined this family
and the son is just like yeah look I get
what's happening here you're either a
jing or a Meo that's that's how the
freaks family works now one of the
biggest and I suppose purposely open
questions about this ending is whether
or not gone regains the use of nen
because he definitely leaves whale
Island probably quite frequently and may
have gone on to continue his career as a
hunter but whether or not he does that
with nen is impossible to say
technically you don't actually need nen
to be h Hunter but because this is the
rejected ending I'd say that he probably
does get nen back because that's the
more standard ending that people would
want to see more nen more Adventures
more happily ever after Etc but I don't
think it's what Togashi would want which
is why I'm actually more inclined to
believe that gone actually would have n
back in this ending now the most curious
part of ending D is the bird flying over
the town as we are given flashes of
various characters that I think are
implied to be the children and
grandchildren of the other main cast
members it's very vague and again
purposely so I do think the sending was
quite deliberately constructed so that
you can read into it however you like my
guess is that you would see a character
who sort of looks or acts like kilawa
Leorio or kopa which means that you
could take this as good news because it
means that Leorio and kopa would have
survived the Dark Continent voyage and
gone on to procreate however it could
also be a bit more Bittersweet than that
you could read it as seeing this next
Generation which while biologically
unrelated to the main cost are going to
have their own Adventures however Grand
or mundane they may be I guess the
weirdest thing to Recon is why they'd
all be living in the same town which is
so close to whale Island I mean kilawa I
could actually see settling down on
whale Island itself because that's you
know where gone his besti is and killer
was actually being there so he has a
connection but if this is his descendant
then they're just living in the town
over but then again you can also make
the argument for any of them deciding to
pack up and living the simple life
because it's completely open-ended it
provides enough vague detail for the
reader to construct their own ideal
ending it's very stereotypical a bit
Bland honestly and I can see why Togashi
has ruled it out as a possibility
actually reminds me a lot of the uaka
show ending the last chapter of that
series is very much a vague Montage like
this there's nothing really you know
final to grasp onto and I think that if
Togashi did choose to go with this
ending then it would only be out of the
sheer fear of the backlash for the
endings that he would prefer to take and
you know it's a really bizarre position
for us as readers to be in because if
the worst happens to Togashi and he
passes away before completing the series
then this is the ending we have which is
for all intents and purposes the happy
ending whereas if Togashi does manage to
complete Hunter Hunter as we all hope
and dream then what we'll probably get
is more along the lines of the sour
dissatisfying ending so good things
equal bad and bad things equal good but
until further notice ending D is our
finale of Hunter Hunter so let me know
what you think of it in the comments as
well as which of the endings you would
personally like to see the most for me
it's ending C no matter how horrible it
may be I want the one that Togashi has
his heart set on the most